les antilles où l'on prépare noël
activement mais avec moins d'attachement
la tradition qu'auparavant c'est du
moins ce que pense trois habitants sur
quatre localement du coup pour relancer
le goût des coutumes et des saveurs des
îles des scolaires ont été initiées le
temps d'une journée aux préparatifs du
réveillon locale ces cristaux d'un jour
après ma préparer un repas de noël
pas n'importe lequel dans la plus pure
tradition martiniquaise
c'est l'un des ateliers du noël antan
lontan organisée par le parc naturel
régional de la martinique pour six
classes de lille mais ces élèves de
cours moyens 1 et 2 koné style seulement
la composition du repas traditionnel du
cochon du pâté jambon pâtes et salé
ragoût de porc ignames les pois d'angole
sont préparés tour à tour à coup sûr les
papilles aideront la mémoire à s'en
souvenir
prochaine étape atelier musique et
chants de noël ici seuls tambour tu y
vois et chacha en droit de cité cette
journée autour des goûts de la tradition
fait partie d'un projet pédagogique
annuel les sciences de la vie de la
terre et l'éducation à la citoyenneté
sont également abordés pour le parc
naturel régional
cette action s'insère dans sa mission
d'éducation à l'environnement et
connaissances du patrimoine
ils auront à passer la conquête mais
doivent posséder ce qui nous appartient
donc la noël fête une occasion foutra
fenêtre sur quoi nous vend les scellés
par une autre grande journée autour de
la tradition les attend sur le thème de
pâques